in today's video we're gonna break down
the five biggest problems with harry
potter and the sorcerer's stone
the movie people of the internet
retrorec and tour here
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games
harry potter and the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube
as much as i love the harry potter book
series and even though the movies do at
least
a respectable job of capturing the
spirit of the books they aren't without
their problems
so we're going to go through my list of
the first film's five biggest
issues number one a weak story
overall harry potter and the sorcerer's
stone does a great job at introducing us
to the wizarding world for the first
time
it captures the spirit and sets the
stage for what's to come but certain
aspects of the story that worked in book
form
don't translate as well to film while it
earns top marks for bringing the
wizarding world to life with the
incredible visuals of places like diagon
alley and hogwarts
the story itself doesn't manage to keep
up with the rapid pace of the novel
the core of book one's plot is centered
on the mystery of the sorcerer's stone
with harry ron and hermione attempting
to unravel the mystery on their own
one of the largest driving forces behind
this plot thread is the relationship
between harry
and professor snape and while we
certainly get scenes between the two in
the movie we miss out on harry's inner
dialogue and his complete bewilderment
at why one of the professors would
seemingly despise him so much
of course in the book he's strongly
suspicious of snape throughout and it
comes as
quite the revelation when professor
quirrell is revealed as the one
attempting to steal the sorcerer's stone
rather than snape
in the movie quirrell always came off as
a little bit obvious
perhaps he was obvious in the books as
well but considering how young i was
when i read them it's really not a
surprise that i didn't pick up on that
how about you guys for any of you out
there who read the harry potter books
before you saw the movies did you
suspect
snape all along or did you see the
quarrel twist coming i'd love to hear
your thoughts down in the comments
number two is the acting and to be
completely fair here this one was
largely unavoidable with the movie
needing so many young and in some cases
inexperienced actors to play prominent
roles
we all know dan radcliffe emma watson
and rupert grint would grow into their
roles over time but there were some
rocky moments in the early going
to wb's credit they balanced out the
child actors by pairing them with an
absolutely stellar lineup of adult cast
members
maggie smith alan rickman richard harris
and robbie coltrane play their roles to
perfection
not to mention those in minor roles like
john hurd as ollivander richard
griffiths as uncle vernon and warwick
davis as professor flitwick
number three no potions challenge while
the first couple movies stayed more true
to the books than the others that would
follow one key scene they missed out on
was the potions challenge near the
climax of the story
before harry can get to the final room
where quirrell is waiting for him with
the mirror of era said
he and hermione must solve what is
essentially a logic puzzle involving
potions
unfortunately this scene was absent from
the film harry got a chance to stand out
with the winged keys and ron proved his
value to the trio with the wizards chess
challenge
the writers probably felt her mindy
stand out moment then would be taken
care of by her quick thinking to escape
the devil's snare
except that's actually not how it
happens in the book in the books it's
actually hermione who panics when the
trio finds themselves within the devil
snare
ron remains calm and helps to calm her
down long enough so she can escape
before the plant has a firm grip
she then frees both harry and ron with
bluebell flames
now keeping this closer to the book
version would have actually given both
ron
and hermione a bit of a standout moment
there in the devil snare trial and then
they could have still went on to give
hermione
another amazing moment had they included
the potions challenge
we know she's smart and we know she's
brave and the potions challenge to me
is just the perfect moment to show both
of those things
and as we all know hermione would go on
to bail out harry and ron numerous times
throughout the rest of the series
thanks to that knowledge and bravery
number 4 the quirrell voldemort timeline
harry and quirrell meet for the first
time in the leaky cauldron before the
start of term at hogwarts
in the movie squirrel already has his
turban and doesn't shake harry's hand
when offered
this would seem to imply that quirrell
knew he couldn't touch harry
and yet at the end of the movie he
appears confused after touching harry
only to find his hand as burned
this took place differently in the books
and would help to make both scenes make
more sense
in the book version quirrell and harry
still meet in the leaky cauldron however
quirrell
doesn't yet have his turban he actually
goes on to shake harry's hand in the
books as well
quirrell actually doesn't start wearing
the turban in the books until after the
attempted break-in at gringotts which we
know took place
the very same day that he and harry met
this also means that when harry
originally met quirrell in the leaky
cauldron
voldemort had not yet possessed him this
may seem like a minor detail however it
would certainly have made quarrels shock
in the final scene
make more sense had they followed the
book timeline a little more closely
number five no peeves the poltergeist
how could the movies leave out peeves
yes he's a minor character but longtime
fans know
just how much comic relief peeves
provides throughout the series
he wouldn't have even needed to be
featured prominently to make an impact
he's one of those characters who can
make just
random off-the-cuff comments and still
serve his purpose
as a result of peeves not being in we
lose out on the scene where harry
impersonates the bloody baron while he's
hiding under the invisibility cloak
which is
a scene i just loved from the books now
believe it or not peeves was
actually cast and even filmed some
scenes for sorcerer's stone before
director chris columbus ultimately
decided to cut the part
apparently columbus ended up not being
satisfied with the final look for peeves
and that's why he said
getting rid of it at least that's what
the most common story is
who knows what really happened i
personally love re-watching the movies
for the nostalgia and being such a fan
of the world i can appreciate them even
without a strong plot to propel that
viewing experience forward
if you've never seen the movies before
they're certainly worth watching at
least once
and for long time fans they'll be
something you want to revisit again and
again as the years go by even if they do
have their share of flaws as always guys
and gals thank you so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon